hey this is presh talwalkar
consider a large circle from which four
smaller circles have been removed
each of the smaller circles passes
through the center of the large circle
and touches the boundary of the large
circle the smaller circles are in the
north east south and west positions
if these four smaller circles are
removed from the large circle
what is the area that remains in other
words what is the area of the shaded
region in the following diagram
which is the area of the region between
the large circle and the boundary of
these four smaller circles
the large circle's diameter equals 84.
this problem was asked to primary school
students in singapore
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so this problem can be solved in many
different methods and in this video i'm
going to present three of them
in the first method
we're going to construct a large square
by connecting the points where exactly
two of the circles intersect
what's useful about this square is that
it's going to cover up the regions in
which these circles overlap
so we can now calculate the area that we
need to remove
by considering the areas of five
different shapes which do not overlap
in particular the shaded area
is equal to the area of the large circle
minus the area of the square minus the
area of 4 semi-circles
the large circle has a diameter of 84
and each of the small circles has a
diameter that's half as long so it's 42.
the square
has a side that's equal to the diameter
of a semi-circle so its side is equal to
42.
a circle has an area of pi r squared and
a square has an area of s squared
the four semi-circles are equal to two
circles
so we can now substitute in the
dimensions of each of these shapes
and we end up with an expression for the
area of the shaded region
the answer will be 882 pi minus 1764
which is approximately 1006.885
so this method is nice because we don't
have to evaluate the region in which two
of the smaller circles overlap
in the next method we'll go ahead and do
that explicitly
what we'll do is we'll consider this
square
we'll connect the center of one of the
smaller circles
to the points in which the two circles
intersect two adjacent circles intersect
so now
the area where these two circles
intersect can be found as follows
this will actually be equal to the area
of two of these quarter circles from
each of these smaller squares
minus
the area of this square
so to show you where these two quarter
circles come from i'm going to separate
them
so now you can see where that
overlapping region comes from
now each quarter circle has an area of
pi r squared over 4 and the square has
an area of s squared
this square has a side length of 21
because it's equal to the radius of one
of the smaller circles
we can now substitute in these
dimensions and then simplify our
expression
so we get the area of overlap between
two adjacent circles is equal to
220.5 pi minus 441
so how is this going to help us solve
the problem that we need
well we want to know the area of the
region we've removed
so this will be equal to the area of the
four lot smaller circles and then we
have four of these overlapping regions
so we don't want to over count the area
that we're removing so we're going to
have to add back these overlapping
regions
in other words we have the area of the
shaded region is equal to the area of
the large circle
minus the area of four of the smaller
circles
and then we add back in four of these
overlapping regions to make sure we're
not double counting the area that we're
removing
so we substitute in the formulas for
these areas and the dimensions
and then what we end up it's actually
kind of interesting you can see the
large circle actually has an area that's
equal to four of the smaller circles so
the area of the shaded region is
actually equal to the area of these four
overlapping regions between two of the
smaller circles this is 882 pi minus
1764 or approximately 1006.885
so while this method was a little more
complicated we actually learned a couple
of things we didn't learn from the first
method
so i'm now going to present one more way
to calculate the area between two of the
overlapping circles
i'll draw in an isosceles right triangle
in one of the smaller circles
this divides the overlapping region
between an upper and a lower region
i'm going to move the lower region from
inside the triangle to outside the
triangle
and now what we have is that the area of
the overlapping region between two
circles is equal to the area of the
semi-circle minus the area of the
isosceles right triangle
the area of the semicircle is pi r
squared over 2 and the area of the
triangle is equal to its base times its
height divided by 2.
triangle has a height that's equal to
the radius of the semicircle which is 21
and its base is equal to the diameter of
the smallest circle which is 42.
so we can now substitute in these
dimensions
and then simplify to get that the area
of the overlap between two of the
smaller circles is again
220.5 pi minus 441.
we then proceed just as we did in the
second part of the two where we
calculate the shaded region by
subtracting out from the large circle
for the smallest circles and then adding
back in for these overlapping regions
we've already calculated each of these
so now we can get to the exactly the
same answer of 882 pi minus 1764 which
is approximately 1006.885
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshellwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description